This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Joy is essential and it's also elusive. But now, there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之百真人。快乐至关重要，却又难以捉摸。不过现在，有一个全新且激动人心的方法，开启你通往更快乐生活的新旅程。快乐101。这是一个全新的播客，由我，霍达·科特比主持。如果你渴望获得最大化快乐的灵感，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的现场聊天。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。
Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS. Hey, it's Alec Baldwin. This season on my podcast, Here's the Thing. I talk to composer Mark Shaman. It's about the hang. It's the pleasure of hanging out with the people that you're with. You know, Rob and I was always a great hang.
搜索“快乐101”并立即收听。由CVS为您呈现的《快乐101》，主持人是霍达·科特比。嘿，我是亚历克·鲍德温。本季我的播客是《原来如此》。我将与作曲家马克·沙曼进行对话。这关乎相处之道。这是与你同行之人共度时光的乐趣。你知道，罗布和我一直都很合得来。
And director Morgan Neville. Film School teaches you all the wrong things about making documentary. What do you want to say? Documentary is all about your ear. What do you hear? I feel like my job is listening really, really hard. Listen to Here's the Thing on the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts.
还有导演摩根·内维尔。电影学院教给你的关于制作纪录片的全都是错的。你想表达什么？纪录片全在于你的耳朵。你听到了什么？我觉得我的工作就是非常、非常认真地倾听。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《原来如此》。
It just came out. Jeremy, what did you just do? You just sit yourself up for failure. I've never heard you tell this story. I've never told this story. This must have been tucked deep, deep in the Jeremy Lynn file. My name is MC Jen. I'm excited to tell you about laugh but not least.
它刚刚发布。杰瑞米，你刚才做了什么？你简直是自寻死路。我从没听过你讲这个故事。我也从没讲过这个故事。这个故事一定被深深地、深深地藏在林书豪的档案里。我叫MC珍。我很高兴向大家介绍《不落俗套的笑声》。
I'll be chatting with guests from all walks of life about the power of humor when it comes to facing difficult times. These will be conversations that remind us all. Life is hard. laugh harder. Listen and laugh but not least with MC Jen on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Happy pride from the Outspoken Podcast Network. All month long and all year round, we're celebrating being loud, proud, and always original. It's me, Brandon Kyle Goodman, host of the podcast, Tell Me Something Messy. Check out my show for unfiltered takes on dating, relationships, and adulting.
我将与各行各业的嘉宾聊天，探讨在面对艰难时期时幽默的力量。这些对话将提醒我们所有人：生活不易，笑对人生。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听MC珍主持的《不落俗套的笑声》。来自直言不讳播客网络的“骄傲月”祝福。一整个月乃至一整年，我们都在庆祝自己声音响亮、引以为傲且始终独一无二。我是布兰登·凯尔·古德曼，播客《告诉我一些混乱的事》的主持人。收听我的节目，获取关于约会、恋爱和成人的最真实观点。
Listen to High Key for the best pop culture takes, and there are no girls on the internet for all your tech news. favorite celebrity Kikis, check out outlaws with T.S. Madison. Learn to love yourself unapologetically with BFF, Black Fat Fem, and start your day with intention with waking up with Ryan coming in July. Celebrate Pride with the Outspoken Network. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Pride and Listen Now. This Black Music Month, the Questlove show celebrates the visionaries, shaping culture, Drusown, from country trailblazer Mickey Gaidon to hip-hop icon Fat 5 Freddie, The sonic genius of Thundercat and the revolutionary voice of Chuck D. I want it loud.
收听《High Key》获取最佳流行文化观点，还有《互联网上没有女孩》满足你所有的科技新闻。想要了解最喜爱的名人八卦，请查看T.S.麦迪逊主持的《逃犯》。通过《BFF（黑胖女性）》学会毫无歉意地爱自己，并在七月即将推出的由瑞安主持的《伴随清晨醒来》中开启充满意图的一天。与直言不讳网络一同庆祝骄傲月。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。搜索“Pride”并立即收听。在这个黑人音乐月，奎斯特洛夫秀致敬塑造文化的远见者们，从乡村开拓者米奇·盖顿到嘻哈偶像法特·弗雷迪，从雷霆猫的音乐天才到查克·D的革命性嗓音。我希望声音开到最大。
So the timing might be off, the sound might be muffled, but what's going to come out of there is something that you can feel. Celebrate Black Music Month with special episodes of the Questlove show. Listen on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. I'm Jemis Speg and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes. moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. It is so great to have you here back for another episode of the psychology of your 20s back for another bonus episode. I'm kind of doing it old school. I'm like bringing it
所以时机可能不对，声音也可能有些沉闷，但从那里传出来的将是你能感受到的东西。通过奎斯特洛夫秀的特别节目庆祝黑人音乐月。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。大家好。我是杰米·斯佩格，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十多岁时最大的改变、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。很高兴你能来到这里，收听《你二十多岁的心理学》的另一集节目，收听另一个番外篇。我有点在走老路。我好像把它
back to the early days, the like early 2021, 2021, 22 days of the podcast where I would get on the mic and just talk about random stuff, random things in my bedroom. I was going to do like a bonus episode today on Freud and on false memories and all this stuff. And I was like, I just don't really feel like it. I actually just feel like chatting. And so I'm going to do it. I was like, oh, wait, this is actually my podcast. I can just chat. I can just talk to you guys about my life and what I've been up to and my 20s rather than like the psychology behind it. And I thought what would be like a good kind of topic, kind of structured to this episode, so I don't just go off on tangents, is a little bit of like a London update and a
带回了早期，也就是播客刚起步的2021年、2021、22年的日子，那时我会坐在麦克风前，只在卧室里聊一些随机的事情、随机的东西。我本来想今天做一个关于弗洛伊德、虚假记忆以及所有这些内容的番外篇。然后我想了想，我其实不太想讲那个。我其实只想随便聊聊。所以我打算这么做了。我想，哦，等等，这实际上是我的播客。我可以随便聊天。我可以跟你们聊聊我的生活、我一直在忙的事情以及我二十多岁的生活，而不是去讲背后的心理学。我想，这集的什么话题会比较好、比较有结构性呢，这样我就不会扯得太远，那就是一点伦敦的近况，以及
little bit of an update around how my life is in London since moving here at the start of the year and things that I've been learning, things that I've been realizing, particularly this like one reoccurring theme that I am spotting in my life, which is kind of a failure or an inability to be in the season of life that I am currently in. And being in London has, because it has been such, like one of the biggest shocks to my system and I guess to my life, has put this in clearer perspectives than any other situation has. Like, it's become so evident to me that this is a problem for me, that I cannot just like sit in the chapter of life that I am in.
一些关于我自今年初搬到伦敦以来，生活是怎样的近况，以及我一直在学到的东西、意识到事情，特别是这个我在生活中发现的一个反复出现的主题，那就是某种失败，或者说无法真正融入我目前所处的生活阶段。而且在伦敦生活，因为它对我的身体系统带来了巨大的冲击，我想也对我的生活带来了巨大冲击，所以它比任何其他情况都让我看得更清楚。就像，这对我来说变得如此明显，这是一个问题，我不能只是安于我目前所处的生活篇章。
I am constantly thinking ahead, constantly thinking of something. better, constantly getting to the place I want to be and then being like, okay, so what's next? And this is the thing, oh my God, I'm really just jumping straight into it. But this is what I've realized with London. I spent two years, two years imagining my life here, two years, I guess preparing. And if you guys know the story, basically I have to wait for my boyfriend Tom to finish an accreditation for his job so that we could move here. And being very patient and being like, when I get to London, like my real adult life is going to start and my 20s are going to really start and this big adventure is going to occur and I'm going to be so happy and I'm
我总是想着未来，总是想着更好的事情，总是想要到达我想去的地方，然后又觉得：好吧，接下来是什么？就是这样，天哪，我真的是直接切入正题了。但这正是我对伦敦的认识。我花了两两年时间，想象着我在这里的生活，两年时间，我想我一直在做准备。如果你们知道这个故事，基本上我不得不等待我的男朋友汤姆完成他工作的资格认证，这样我们才能搬到这里。并且表现得非常有耐心，心想：当我到了伦敦，我的真正的成年生活就要开始了，我二十多岁的人生要真正开始了，这场宏大的冒险将会发生，我会非常快乐，而且我
going to be so fulfilled and my career is going to be great. I'm going to be a city gal. And I've been here now for eight months and the only thing I want is to move home. And all I can think about is like, oh my God, how good is it going to be when we go back to Australia? How good is it going to be when we go back to Australia and we're going to buy a big piece of land like in Queensland and we get to build our home and I really want to build like a big community space with like art like rooms for like artist retreats and like for community meals and I want to build like a like a small rescue facility we can get sheltered dogs like blah blah blah blah and I'm like wait what what has just happened here because
会感到非常充实，我的事业也会很棒。我要成为一个都市丽人了。而我现在已经在这里八个月了，我唯一的愿望就是搬回家。我脑子里想的全都是：天哪，当我们回到澳大利亚时，该有多美好啊！当我们回到澳大利亚，我们要在昆士兰买一大块土地，我们要建自己的家，我真的想建一个像大型社区空间一样的地方，有艺术室之类的房间供艺术家静修，还有供社区聚餐的地方，我还想建一个小型救援设施，我们可以收留流浪狗之类的，啦啦啦啦啦。然后我想：等等，这里到底发生了什么？因为
again I just explained it. spent all this time wanting this future, wanting this reality, which it is now. It's my reality, the moment that I am in, and I'm here. And it hasn't been terrible. It's actually been quite great. And suddenly I'm like, okay, what's next? What's next? And this inability to sit and be happy with the moment, with the season, with the chapter that I currently inhabit is, I'm kind of recognizing a little bit of a problem. So I've basically just given you everything. we're going to talk about right off the bat. But there's a bit more complexity to it. I kind of want to discuss. I have gotten a lot of questions I should say from people who are like,
再次说明，我刚刚解释过了。我花了所有这些时间渴望这个未来，渴望这个现实，而它现在就是现实了。这就是我身处的当下，我在这里。而且它并没有那么糟糕。实际上它相当棒。突然之间我又觉得：好吧，接下来是什么？接下来是什么？这种无法安于现状、对当下、对季节、对自己目前所处的篇章感到快乐的无能为力，我开始意识到这其实是个问题。所以我基本上开门见山地把我们要谈的一切都告诉你们了。但其中还有更多的复杂性。我其实想讨论一下。我应该说，我收到了很多人的提问，他们问：
hey, how is London? I'm about to move. I'm thinking of moving. I'm thinking of moving not to London, but in general, what's been your experience? So I thought I'd go through that and then talk about one I'm planning to leave, I guess. And this more general pathological, um, kind of inability to be, I was going to say inability to be happy. Inability to be happy. Inability to be happy, no, inability to be at ease with my life. So we have been in London now for, we moved in December, so it's, what is it, June, so six months, seven months at this point. I would say we moved at a terrible time. And I can see that in hindsight that we did not plan our move well. Firstly, we moved right as the podcast was like going on Netflix. And I spoke about this in a
嘿，伦敦怎么样？我正准备搬过去。我在考虑搬家。我考虑搬家，不一定是去伦敦，但总体而言，你的经历是怎样的？所以我想回顾一下这个经历，然后谈谈我打算离开的计划，我想是的。以及这种更普遍的病态的、某种程度上无法存在的状态，我本来想说无法感到快乐。无法感到快乐。无法感到快乐，不，是无法对我的生活感到安心。所以我们现在在伦敦已经呆了，我们是十二月搬来的，所以现在是什么时候，六月，所以此时是六个月，七个月了。我想说我们搬来的时机很糟糕。事后看来，我能看出我们搬家并没有计划好。首先，搬来的时候正值播客要在Netflix上线的时期。我在
previous episode. That was just the most stressful period of my life. Something you may not know about that. I feel like it's this huge crazy thing. You know, the psychology of your 20s on Netflix. It's a massive like career achievement. I genuinely couldn't have dreamed it. It was so stressful because I signed that contract literally four hours before I got on the plane. I really didn't think it was going to happen. And then I got here. We went on holiday with my week. Firstly, I got to London. and we didn't have anywhere to live because the place we were meant to be staying had fallen through. So we had like 10 days or less. I can't remember the timelines to find somewhere to live.
之前的节目里谈过这个。那简直是我人生中最压力的时期。关于那件事，你可能不知道。我觉得这是一件非常疯狂的大事。你知道，Netflix上的《你二十多岁的心理学》。这是一项巨大的职业成就。我真的做梦也没想到。它太让人压力山大了，因为我 literalmente（西班牙语：字面意思）在登机前四小时才签了那份合同。我真的以为这事不会发生。然后我到了这里。我们和我的……首先，我到了伦敦，
And then we went on holiday with my family. And then in the middle of that holiday, I get literally on New Year's Day, New Year's Eve, I get this email from the team being like, hey, we need to get the Netflix episodes going. And I was like, I have literally just moved country. I don't have a studio, I don't have a clue, I don't have anybody really to help me. So the first half of the year was very stressful. I think if we had known that was going to happen, we probably would have held off. The other thing that if you've moved to London or thinking of it that you'll hear come up a lot is do you move in summer or do you move in winter?
我们没有地方住，因为我们原本打算住的地方泡汤了。所以我们只有大约10天或更少的时间来找地方住。我不记得具体时间线了。然后我和家人去度假了。然后在度假的中途，我 literalmente（字面意思），就在元旦那天，除夕那天，我收到了团队的电子邮件，说：嘿，我们需要开始制作Netflix的剧集了。当时我的反应是：我刚刚搬到一个国家。我没有工作室，我毫无头绪，我真的没有任何人可以帮我。所以上半年压力非常大。我想如果我们知道会这样，我们可能会推迟。另一件事是，如果你搬到伦敦或正在考虑搬到伦敦，你会经常听到这样的问题：你是夏天搬来还是冬天搬来？
The thing with moving in winter is that you are basically guaranteeing that the first three to four months is going to be miserable and rotten, but then you get the reward of summer, right? And when you go into summer, by that stage, you probably have a few friends. You probably have a bit more of a community. You have a bit more of a foundation so you can really enjoy the summer. And then the comparative kind of option is that you move in the summer. It's great because you move in. It's just the city comes alive. But then you kind of are, the lull comes during the winter.
冬天搬来的问题在于，你基本上是在确保头三到四个月会非常悲惨和糟糕，但随后你就能收获夏天的回报，对吧？当你进入夏天时，到那个阶段，你可能已经有了一些朋友。你可能已经有了更多的社区基础。你有了更多的人脉基础，所以你可以真正享受夏天。与之相比的另一种选择是夏天搬来。这很棒，因为你搬进来时，城市正焕发生机。但随后你就会发现，低谷期会在冬天到来。
We did the first one. It was pretty miserable. I've done an episode before on seasonal depression. and when I lived in Canberra, I definitely had a bite of that apple. Like, I definitely had experienced it. Well, I thought I had. No. No, no, no, no.
我们选了第一种。确实挺惨的。我以前做过一期关于季节性抑郁的节目，当我住在堪培拉时，我绝对尝过那种滋味。我的确经历过。嗯，我以为我经历过。不。不不不不。
It was, I had no words to describe the deep sadness. The deep sadness. I was like, oh my gosh. No wonder such sad literature comes from cold. climates. Like, you guys have ice and chill in your bones, like sadness. And that's what it felt like. And so we really struggled with that. And then also my boyfriend Tom was just looking for a job. And that's like the next thing I'll talk about in terms of just like advice for people who want to move here. The job market just from seeing people navigating it is so tricky. And I remember hearing stories.
那种深沉的悲伤，我简直无法用言语来形容。那种深沉的悲伤。当时我想：天哪。难怪如此悲伤的文学作品都出自寒冷的气候。就像，你们的骨子里有冰和寒冷，有悲伤。这就是我的感受。所以我们对此真的很挣扎。然后我的男朋友汤姆也在找工作。这就是我接下来要谈的，关于给想搬到这里的人的建议。从我看到人们的经历来看，这里的就业市场太棘手了。我记得听到过一些故事。
Like with Australia and the UK, there is a long, obviously, we're a Commonwealth country. So we have this like basically we are quote unquote owned by the UK. And what that's kind of meant is that through many generations, like Australians will go, like every generation kind of goes to the UK. Like there is this kind of tidal wave around like the ages of 23 to 28 where like, you know, 25% of Australians will probably move to London or will move to the UK. And most people that I know have a friend or I know people. people who have done it and our parents generation have done it like it's a very like a cultural thing
就像澳大利亚和英国之间，显然有着悠久的历史，我们是一个英联邦国家。所以我们基本上可以说是被英国“拥有”的。这意味着经过许多代人的繁衍，澳大利亚人会去，每一代人基本上都会去英国。就像在23到28岁这个年龄段，会有一股浪潮，大概25%的澳大利亚人可能会搬到伦敦或搬到英国。我认识的大多数人都有朋友，或者我认识有人做过这件事，我们父母那一辈也做过，这非常像是一种文化现象。
and I remember talking to my parents and then also you know friends parents as well you know aunts and uncles and everybody then being like oh my god moving to the UK is an amazing opportunity you go you make more money it's you just the opportunities are everywhere and it feels like that is a very outdated narrative and of course we did know that we understand stand the state of the world, but you really can't overstay how different it was from like the glory days of like my parents' generation and their friends' generation of like, move to London and you get, you get this job and like, you make all this money because there's all this capital. And it's like, no, no, no, no, no. The reality is so different. And again, I will say, like,
我记得跟我父母谈过，还有朋友的父母，叔叔阿姨们，每个人都说：天哪，搬到英国是一个绝佳的机会，你去那里能赚更多钱，机会到处都是。感觉这是一种非常过时的说法。当然，我们知道，我们了解世界的现状，但你真的无法夸大它与我父母那代人和他们朋友那代人的“黄金时代”有多么不同，那时候“搬到伦敦，你就能找到工作，由于有大量资本，你能赚很多钱”。事实并非如此。不，不，不，不，不。现实太不一样了。再说一次，我会说，
we knew that. We were, we weren't naive coming into it. But very few things prepare you for how much money you will spend, how quickly you will chew through your savings, and how difficult it will be to find a job, I think, in most industries. And I say that because Tom's a lawyer, he struggled in that space. But every other friend that I have people who work in design, people who work in even retail, people who work in museums, people who work in consulting, people who work in, like, all these different industries have all said, like, it is a struggle. Like if you get a job offer in the first three months, you have done exceptionally well. So I was going to go into like the best and worst things of our experience in London so far.
我们知道这一点。我们来的时候并不天真。但很少有事情能让你做好心理准备，让你知道自己会花掉多少钱，积蓄会烧得有多快，而且在大多数行业找工作会有多难。我这么说是因为汤姆是一名律师，他在那个领域举步维艰。但我认识的其他所有朋友，在设计领域工作的人，甚至在零售业工作的人，在博物馆工作的人，在咨询行业工作的人，在各种不同行业工作的人，都纷纷表示：这太艰难了。如果你在前三个月拿到一份工作Offer，那你已经做得极其出色了。我本来想谈谈我们在伦敦经历中迄今为止最好和最糟糕的事情。
I would say that period of me and Tom's kind of like journey here was very, very difficult. Finding an apartment not so difficult. I thought that was going to be really hard. We moved at a time when they said it's like one of the best times to find places it was in December. Definitely didn't feel that way because we were scrambling. but we have such a beautiful place. It is my dream apartment in a way that's like, it's my dream apartment for my 20s, right? There's definitely things like we're on the top floor, like the fourth floor of this terrace house and there's no elevator.
我要说的是，我和汤姆在这里的那段旅程非常、非常艰难。找公寓倒不是很难。我以为那会非常难。我们搬家的时候，据说那是找房子的最好时机之一，那是十二月份。但绝对没有那种感觉，因为我们当时手忙脚乱的。不过我们有一个非常漂亮的住所。这可以说是二十多岁时我梦想中的公寓，对吧？当然也有一些问题，比如我们在顶楼，也就是这栋露台住宅的四楼，而且没有电梯。
And right now as I'm recording this, it is a massive heat wave and there is no aircon and all the heat rises. And I cannot express to you how hot it is here. A lot of people have been asking me, you know, it's a heat wave in London. Like, surely you're used to this. you're Australian, you're like, you spent your summers in Queensland and like, no, it's, it's no, it's so different. It's, the, the structures and the facilities and like the infrastructure, I should say, is not built for this heat. And definitely, we've been feeling that. But what was I talking about? Yes, our apartment is gorgeous. It has this, like, um, mezzanine. It's like a loft apartment.
就在我录音的现在，正值一场巨大的热浪，这里没有空调，所有的热气都往上升。我无法向你们表达这里有多热。很多人问我：伦敦现在有热浪，你肯定习惯了吧？你是澳大利亚人，你在昆士兰度过夏天。不，完全不是，真的完全不一样。这里的建筑、设施，或者说基础设施，根本不是为这种热浪建造的。我们确实深有体会。不过我刚才说到哪儿了？对了，我们的公寓非常华丽。它有一个类似夹层的设计，就像一个阁楼公寓。
So, like, the bottom floor is, like, where our bedroom is and our lounge room and our bathroom and then the top floor is like a second bedroom slash living room that has a view of the entirety of London and we didn't even realize until we moved in like the whole London skyline you can see from our top floor window and it's like one of my favorite things is to be like oh my god yeah come over and see our see our view so that's a that's a pro job job hunting con making friends has been relatively easy I know I said in my episode when I was like I'm moving to London, just so you guys know, I was like, I'm most worried about this. This is, and I'm speaking from personal experience, so if this wasn't your experience, again, it's, don't think that you've done
所以底楼是我们的卧室、客厅和浴室，然后顶楼是第二个卧室兼起居室，能看到整个伦敦的全景。直到搬进来我们才意识到，从顶楼的窗户可以看到整个伦敦的天际线。我最喜欢的事情之一就是说：哦，天哪，快过来看看我们的风景。所以这是一个优点。找工作是缺点。交朋友相对容易。我知道我在节目里说过，当我宣布要搬到伦敦时，为了让你们知道，我当时说：我最担心这个。这是我根据个人经验说的，所以如果这不是你的经历，同样地，不要觉得你做错了什么。
anything wrong, but this has been the easiest city for me to make friends in. And maybe it was the attitude that I came in with, which was like, I need to make friends. And I'm, it's going to be a mission. This is as important as finding an apartment, as important as finding a job for like, for Tom and, you know, and for establishing our careers here. And we just kind of went home. And we were just so rewarded with just incredible friendships and not just Australians. We also were friends with people who are born and bright in the UK,
有什么不妥的，但这绝对是我交朋友最轻松的一个城市。也许是因为我来的时候心态很好，就觉得我需要交朋友，这会是一个任务。这和找公寓、找工作一样重要，对汤姆和我，以及我们在建立的事业来说都很重要。我们只是顺其自然，结果收获了极其珍贵的友谊，而且不只是澳大利亚人，我们还和在英国出生长大的人交朋友，
which I think is like a stereotype of like Aussies and Kiwis move over here and then all their friends are just, or Americans or whoever, move over here and they just remain in their interior circles. But no, we have this amazing community. That has been a huge pro. A con going back and forth. has been, I think, the impact on my emotional state, though. So this is kind of a good segue into why I want to go home now.
我觉得这就像是个刻板印象，比如澳洲人和新西兰人搬到这里，然后他们所有的朋友，或者美国人还是谁，搬来之后只在自己的小圈子里活动。但并不是这样，我们拥有一个了不起的社群。这是一个巨大的优点。不过来回奔波的一个缺点，我觉得是对我的情绪状态产生的影响。所以这也算是一个很好的过渡，讲讲为什么我现在想回家了。
I'm done. I'm ready to leave. I've done it. Which I'm not at that level yet, but London has definitely made me angrier. It has made me more irritable. It has made me a less forgiving person. And that is in every kind of area of my life. You know, it's very, I come home and navigating the tube system and navigating public transport
我受够了，我准备离开了，我都体验过了。虽然我还没到那种程度，但伦敦确实让我变得更暴躁了，让我更容易生气，让我变成了一个没那么宽容的人。这种情况体现在我生活的方方面面。你知道的，我回到家，坐地铁，搭乘公共交通，
and navigating crowds and all that means that I get home and I'm like, I'm cranky. Somebody like, your steps in front of me, I'm like, I'm cranky. Oh my God. Can I say what my biggest issue with London is? Choose the side of the path. Oh, my God. I can't believe I haven't mentioned this at some point. In Australia, and obviously, sorry, I know I keep like being like, in Australia, in Australia, in Australia.
应付拥挤的人流等等，这些都导致我一回家就脾气暴躁。如果有人挡在我前面，我就会很生气。天哪！我能说说我对伦敦最大的意见是什么吗？走在人行道靠边一点啊！天哪，我真不敢相信我之前竟然没提到过这一点。在澳大利亚，当然了，对不起，我知道我一直像这样说：在澳大利亚，在澳大利亚，在澳大利亚。
But in Australia, like, and in most countries, it's like you walk on the right or you walk on the left. They're what? They don't seem to compute that that makes things more efficient. And so that has been like a real adjustment. I think that and also the heat recently and just how many people are in the city, how difficult it is to navigate when you live in central London means that your cognitive load is just significant. And I guess my final con, which is one that's a bit more serious, has been, In my adjustment to this new country and new system is the healthcare system.
但在澳大利亚，还有大多数国家，人们都是靠右走或者靠左走。而这里的人呢？他们似乎完全不觉得那样可以让事情更有效率。所以这真的是一个很大的适应过程。我想这一点，再加上最近的天气很热，以及城市里的人口实在太多，住在伦敦市中心时出行有多么不便，意味着你的大脑承受的负荷相当大。我想我的最后一个缺点，是一个稍微严重一点的问题，那就是我对这个新国家和新系统、也就是医疗系统的适应过程。
And I have really struggled to navigate it. And I've really struggled to just get answers for things. I took a turn there, but you guys know at the start of last year, I had this really insane health scare where I went in for a retinal scan. and my optic nerve was swollen and the doctors were essentially like there are three options. There's the really, really bad option, which is a tumour. There is the still bad but medium option, which is MS or there's this other option which is, like you have too much fluid in your brain.
我真的很难适应它，也真的很难为各种事情得到一个确切的说法。话题有点转折了，但你们知道去年年初的时候，我经历了一次非常疯狂的健康恐慌，当时我去做了视网膜扫描，
And it was this real waiting game of like, well, I fucking hope it's not the first two options and luckily it wasn't, thank God. now I have this condition that I need to manage. And that means that wherever I live, every three to six months, I have to go and see an ophthalmologist and a neurologist to make sure that everything is working as it should be, right? And that my vision is still okay, that other symptoms are being managed,
那真是一场漫长的等待，心想：我他妈希望不是前两项。好在结果不是，感谢上帝。现在我得管理这种状况，这意味着无论我住在哪里，每三到六个月我都必须去看眼科医生和神经科医生，以确保一切运作正常，
because when you have too much fluid in your brain, it's not pleasant. You, duh. Firstly, you can go blind. secondly you get these crazy like headaches that I can't even explain it's like somebody's squeezing you like a pimple and you get this like wishing in your ear that's really irritating so essentially I got here and I was like okay priority number one is I need to get a specialist for this condition that I have I'm still on the wait list I'm still on a wait list and I have found that
因为脑子里积液太多可不是什么好体验。首先，你可能会失明；其次，你会头痛得要命，我都无法形容那种感觉，就像有人在捏你的青春痘一样，而且你的耳朵里会有那种很烦人的嗡嗡声。所以基本上我来到这里后就想：好吧，当务之急是我需要为我得的这个病找个专科医生。我还在等待名单上，我还在等待名单上，而且我发现
understandable because there's a lot of other people who needs to be seen and obviously like it's not like I should come in and get top priority. Not at all, but I just mean, I got on the wait list in February and it's now June and that is just shocking to me, considering the standard of care and like the level of care that I am used to, which is that you'll seem pretty quickly. And maybe it's just my experience because when I was first diagnosed, it was such a, quote, unquote, emergency because they weren't, they didn't have any answers. But I really struggle with that. And then I'm having some other health problems to do with my stomach. And I was, like, crying in my GP's office the other day, just being like, can you help me?
这也可以理解，因为还有很多其他人需要看病，而且显然并不是说我一来就能得到最高优先级。完全不是这样，但我的意思是，我是二月份排上队的，现在已经是六月份了，考虑到我习惯的护理标准和护理水平，这让我感到非常震惊，因为以前你很快就能看上医生。也许这只是我的经历，因为我刚确诊时，这是一个所谓的“紧急情况”，因为医生们当时给不出任何答案。但我真的很难接受这一点。然后我最近还有一些胃部健康问题，前几天我在全科医生的诊室里都快哭了，就差说：你能帮帮我吗？
Like, how I just, and just being like, I don't even know what question to ask you, but can you help me? And she's like, well, I've made the referral. And it's just kind of like, okay, so either you go private and you spend so much money, or you just kind of have to sit and wait. And then, not to give you guys too many private details, but my symptoms were getting worse in a way that's like not unsurious. Like it and I qualified. I was put into like the two week wait list process. So basically if your symptoms get worse, like and you're under the age of 40, they are like, well, we need to see you quickly. And I went back in and I was like, hey, like I did this, you know, we did this test again. And the test is shown that things are getting worse. Can you like now I meet the thing. And she's like, okay, yeah, yeah, I'll put you on the wait list. And. I haven't heard anything. And so there's been a lot of stress and anxiety around what is going on in my body. How do I access healthcare here? Is it worth paying the money? And just not really
就好像我甚至不知道该问你什么问题，但你能帮帮我吗？她说：好吧，我已经帮你转诊了。然后就感觉：好吧，要么你去看私立医生花一大笔钱，要么你就只能坐在这里干等。然后，并不是想给你们透露太多私密细节，但我的症状正在恶化，情况可不是无足轻重的那种。我符合了条件，被放进了两周的等待名单流程里。所以基本上，如果你的症状恶化，而且你不到40岁，他们就会觉得：好吧，我们需要尽快给你看病。我又去了诊所，然后说：嘿，我做了这个测试。测试显示情况在恶化。你能……现在我符合条件了吧。她说：好吧，行，行，我把你加到等待名单上。然后，我什么消息都没听到。所以围绕着我身体到底出了什么问题，我感到非常大压力和焦虑。我怎么才能在这里看病？花这笔钱值得吗？而且真的不知道
knowing how to do it. And this isn't to say like the NHS isn't a great system, right? This isn't to say that public healthcare isn't a genuine miracle. It's just that compared to what I'm used to, finding the difference really scary because I'm expecting answers or I'm expecting a way of communicating that is different to like what I'm experiencing. Like for example, I got this appointment and it was like, okay, this is, that your appointment is at 5 a.m. on like the 3rd of July. And it was weird because I was like, but nobody asked me if I'm available then and I'm not. Nobody like called me and I'm so used to being like, okay, well, I choose my appointment time because why give somebody an appointment time they can't go to if they're just going to have to cancel.
该怎么做。这并不是说NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）不是一个伟大的系统，对吧？这并不是说公立医疗不是一个真正的奇迹。只是相比我习惯的医疗方式，我发现这种差异真的很吓人，因为我期待着答案，或者我期待的沟通方式与我实际经历的不同。比如，我收到了一个预约通知，上面写着：好的，你的预约时间是7月3日早上5点。这真的很奇怪，因为我想：但没有人问过我那个时间有没有空啊，我根本没空。没有人打电话给我，而我习惯的情况是：好吧，我自己选择预约时间，因为既然别人去不了，为什么还要给他们安排一个不得不取消的预约时间呢？
And that just, it's not how it's done here. So that's been quite stressful. And I guess this kind of leads me into why I want to go home. You know, we've done eight months in the UK. And we said at six months time, we would decide whether we wanted to do two years. And the big reason we decided that we've, we kind of had a point where we would decide if we really wanted to stay for a while is also because of our dog. Don't worry, Talu is still very much. much okay she's very loved she is very happy probably the happiest dog in the world she's with my
而且这里办事不是这样的。所以这确实让人压力很大。我想这也引出了我为什么想回家。我们在英国待了八个月了。我们曾在六个月的时候说过，我们会决定是否要待满两年。我们决定是否要在这里待上一段时间的一个重要原因，也是因为我们的狗。别担心，塔鲁现在过得很好，它被深深地爱着，非常快乐，可能是世界上最快乐的狗了。它和我
parents and my sisters and honestly i know she's happy i miss her a lot and it is a daily conversation of like oh i can't wait to see her should we bring her over no yes blah blah blah should we put should we do this should we do that and just trying to decide and essentially at the six month mark we were like we're not going to stay over two years so we're not going to bring her over and also the discussion of like do we like it here? Do we see a future here? And the answer is no. And the answer is no because of a combination of things. The first is, you know what? The first is that it's just not our city. And I saw this post the other day from this girl who was like every person, I can't remember, it was like, everyone feels like spiritually aligned with like one of these three cities. Like, are you a New York
父母以及姐姐们在一起。老实说，我知道它很快乐，我也非常想念它。我们每天都在讨论：“哦，我迫不及待想见它了，我们要把它接过来吗？不，要的，巴拉巴拉，我们应该这样做吗？我们应该那样做吗？”就在那里纠结。基本上在满六个月的时候，我们觉得：我们不会待满两年，所以我们不会把它接过来。还有关于“我们喜欢这里吗？我们在这里看得到未来吗？”的讨论，答案是没有。答案是没有的原因是多种因素的结合。首先，你知道吗？首先，这里根本不是我们的城市。我前几天看到一个女孩发的帖子，大意是每个人……我不记得了，大意是每个人都觉得自己在精神上与以下三座城市之一高度契合。你是一个纽约
girl? Are you a Paris girl? Are you a London girl? And there were all these people in the comments being like, I feel like London spiritually in my body. I feel it in my bones. And I just don't feel that. And I have friends who feel that who are like, I love this city. And I'm really giving it a good go. I am going out.
女孩吗？你是一个巴黎女孩吗？你是一个伦敦女孩吗？评论区里有很多人都在说：我觉得伦敦在精神上融入了我的身体，我在骨子里能感觉得到。但我就是没有这种感觉。我有朋友会有这种感觉，他们会说：我太爱这座城市了，我真的很努力地在融入它，我在到处玩，
I am doing stuff. I have seen so many West End plays. I don't want to see another musical. Can I be real? I don't really like musical theater that much. And I feel like every Friday night, if I don't have plants, I have to go and see something on the West End. And I'm like, I actually don't like this.
我在体验各种事物，我看了好多的西区戏剧。我再也不想看音乐剧了。说真的，我其实没那么喜欢音乐剧。我觉得每个周五晚上，如果我没有别的安排，我就得去看一场西区上演的剧目，而我的真实想法是：我其实一点也不喜欢这样。
And I just think it's like what the city has to offer is not what we enjoy, which is outdoor spaces, beaches, a bit more convenience, yeah, access to nature, better good weather. And just the culture. Like I just think it's not a fit. So as I said at the beginning of this episode, I'm finding myself in this period of like, okay, cool. Time to wrap it up now. Like, oh, my God, I'm already making, I'm like making plans for the future. I'm like saying to Tom and my friends like, oh yeah, when we go back, like, we're going to get this land and we're going to do this and I'm going to fulfill this dream. And I have had to kind of pull it back a little bit and just as I said, enjoy it.
我只是觉得这座城市能提供的不是我们所喜爱的，我们喜欢的是户外空间、海滩、多一点的便利性，以及接触大自然的机会、更好的天气。还有文化氛围。我觉得这里就是不适合我们。所以正如我在这一集开头所说的那样，我发现自己正处于这样一个时期：好吧，酷，现在是时候收尾了。天哪，我已经在制定计划了，我跟汤姆和朋友们说：“哦，是的，等我们回去，我们要买这块地，我们要这样做，我要实现这个梦想。”我不得不稍微克制一下自己，就像我说的，好好享受当下。
Like this is not going to last forever. We now know very conclusively we are not relocating here permanently. This, we're having fun at this point. We're enjoying ourselves, but this is not our place. and so now I'm at this point of like, but you can't just be ready to leave at all times. Like mentally you still need to be checked into this experience because this experience isn't going to last.
这不会永远持续下去。我们现在非常确定地知道，我们不会在这里永久定居。此时此刻我们是在玩得很开心，我们过得很愉快，但这里不是我们的归宿。所以我现在的心态是：你不能随时都想着离开。在精神上，你依然需要全身心投入到这段经历中，因为这段经历是不会一直持续的。
And at some point I know I'm going to go home to Australia, move somewhere else and really miss our time here and miss our apartment and miss our friends and miss our routines and miss what London does have to offer, which is so much. but yeah that's kind of the where am I going with this that's kind of the conundrum that I'm finding myself in which is like enjoy this now and make the most of this experience rather than idealizing the future the same way that you idealize this future and some of the ways we're really trying to like make the most of this time is um just traveling as much as possible and doing a lot of stuff that like you can only do when you live on this side of the equator so
我知道在某个时刻，我要回澳大利亚，搬到别的地方去，然后我会深深怀念在这里的时光，怀念我们的公寓，怀念我们的朋友，怀念我们的日常生活，怀念伦敦所能提供的一切——这里能提供的实在太多了。但话又说回来，这就是我面临的困惑所在，那就是：享受当下，充分利用这段经历，而不是像美化未来那样去美化未来。我们真正试图充分利用这段时间的其中一些方式是，尽可能多地旅行，做很多只有当你生活在赤道这一侧时才能做的事情，所以
if you follow me on Instagram, I honestly feel like I need to apologize by how much I post me being like, I'm in Italy, I'm in Vienna, I'm in, I don't know where else I'm going, I'm in Wales, I'm in the Netherlands. I honestly feel like it's kind of aggressive at times to be like, oh my God, look at me traveling all the time, blah, blah, blah. But that's just a bit of like the tall poppy syndrome in me, I think. But yeah, that's what we've said. We've like, okay, if we're going to leave by June next year, we need to just go. And, you know, we need to just go. go ham on the travel plans. And that's what we've done. We've been like, we need to take advantage of this. We need to take advantage of all that London has to offer. And so we've also kind of
如果你在Instagram上关注了我，老实说我觉得我需要为自己发了那么多动态而道歉，一会儿说我在意大利，一会儿在维也纳，一会儿又不知道去哪儿了，在威尔士，在荷兰。老实说，有时候这感觉有点咄咄逼人，就像是“天哪，看看我一直在旅游，巴拉巴拉”。但我想这只是我内心的“割麦子综合征”（出头鸟心理）在作祟吧。不过是的，这就是我们的决定。我们觉得：好吧，如果我们要赶在明年六月离开，我们就得抓紧了。而且，你知道，我们需要在旅游计划上火力全开。这就是我们一直在做的。我们觉得需要好好利用这一点，需要利用伦敦所能提供的一切。所以我们也
been like, I think the mentality I got in was like, we're going to be back and we're going to execute this next part of our life plan, which is to kind of settle down and to really like build a home and like fulfill a longstanding childhood dream. And mentally I was being a little bit like financially cautious because of that because I was like this is a big financial dream I have for the next five to ten years so I really want to save and Tom was like okay but also this is a situation you're never going to get back we're never going to be able to get this visa again we're probably never going to live on the side of the equator again we need to be yes we can be cautious with our money but also we need to be willing to spend it on experiences and we need to be willing to
觉得，我刚来时的心态是：我们会回去，然后开始执行我们人生规划的下一个阶段，也就是安顿下来，真正建立一个家，实现一个长久以来的童年梦想。所以在精神上，因为这个原因，我在财务上一直有点保守，因为我想这是我未来五到十年的一个重大财务梦想，所以我真的很想存钱。而汤姆则说：好吧，但这也是一种你再也无法获得的体验，我们再也拿不到这个签证了，我们可能再也不会住在赤道这一侧了，我们当然可以在金钱上保持谨慎，但同时我们也需要愿意为体验花钱，我们需要愿意
do the things that we can only do here so we're traveling a lot I've also been better at not complaining about London. I feel like if you're my friend or like a family member, sometimes I can be a little bit annoying with it. Especially with this heat wave, I've been like, I hate it here. I never want to, I don't want, why do we move here? I'm being very cranky and I'm trying to,
去做那些只有在这里才能做的事情。所以我们经常旅行。我也变得更擅长不抱怨伦敦了。我觉得如果你是我的朋友或者家人，有时候我可能会因为这个而有点烦人。特别是遇到这场热浪时，我一直说：我讨厌这里，我再也不想……我们为什么要搬来这里？我当时脾气很暴躁，而我正在努力去……
I understand I think better than anyone, not better than anyone. I just understand that the thoughts that you have prime, how you experience reality. And so when we were in the middle of winter and especially like when it was freezing cold, we just complained so much. And then obviously we'd go outside and every expectation we had was being met by experiences because we were searching for those bad experiences. We were searching for reasons not to like London. And now I'm like, no, I'm going to give London the benefit of the doubt.
我比任何人都更清楚……也不能说比任何人都清楚。我只是明白，你的想法决定了你如何体验现实。所以当我们在严冬中，特别是天寒地冻的时候，我们抱怨得太多了。然后显而易见，当我们走到户外时，我们的每一个预期都会被实际体验所印证，因为我们一直在寻找那些糟糕的体验。我们在寻找不喜欢伦敦的理由。而现在我想：不，我要选择相信伦敦。
I want it to exceed my expectations. Everything she wants to offer me, I'm going to take with open arms. I'm not going to complain about it. I'm just going to. enjoy it and love this experience. So to kind of wrap up this bonus episode, would I recommend moving to London? What are my future plans kind of looking like? I would recommend moving to London. As much as we've made the decision, and obviously I'm preemptively being like, I'm ready to go, get me out of here. It is an amazing experience. It is incredibly expensive. You will not save any
我要让它超出我的预期。它想要带给我的一切，我都将张开双臂去接受。我不会再抱怨了，我只会去享受它，热爱这段经历。所以作为这期特别节目录制的尾声，我会推荐搬来伦敦吗？我未来的计划大概是什么样的？我会推荐搬来伦敦。尽管我们已经做出了决定，而且显然我提前进入了“我准备好了，快带我离开这儿”的状态，但这是一段奇妙的经历。这里物价高得离谱，住在这里你绝对存不下
money while living here. I'm just going to say that. It is incredibly inconvenient at times, but is it worth it? Yes. The experiences that like we have had and I have had, literally last week I was talking on like, I did like a live podcast with my friend Grace on like the second tallest building in London. So one of the tallest buildings in the world and I was like, this is an experience I'm not going to have in Sydney. And that I was just like, that is amazing. I also, guys, I live really close to Tom Hiddleston. I actually know where he lives. He lives, I'm not going to say, I want to say it.
一分钱。我只想直说这一点。这里有时极其不方便，但这一切值得吗？是的。我们所经历的那些体验，我所经历的体验——就在上周，我还在伦敦第二高的建筑里……也就是世界上最高的一些建筑之一，和我朋友格蕾丝一起做了一个现场播客。当时我就觉得：这是我在悉尼绝对不会有的体验。那一刻我觉得：这太棒了。而且，伙计们，我住得离汤姆·希德勒斯顿（Tom Hiddleston）非常近。我其实知道他住哪儿。他就住……我还是不说了，我很想说出来。
But I know where he lives, because he lives near us. He's like our neighbor. And I see him all the time. I see Paul Meskel all the time, which I feel like everybody in London has the local celebrity that they see. And as much as like I try not to be like consumed by like celebrity culture, it's cool. It's cool to be like, hey. like there's tom hiddleston like hey dude like there he is um like we're friends but like that's that's a really it's like a really cool thing i love going to like richmond park i love going to like the heath
但我确实知道他住哪儿，因为他就住在我们附近。他就像我们的邻居一样。我经常看到他。我经常看到保罗·麦斯卡（Paul Mescal），我觉得伦敦的每个人都有自己经常能看到的本地名人。尽管我尽量不让自己被名流文化所吞噬，但这真的很酷。能够像这样说：“嘿，那是汤姆·希德勒斯顿，嘿，兄弟，他就站在那儿，就好像我们是朋友一样”——这真的很酷，太棒了。我喜欢去里士满公园（Richmond Park），我喜欢去汉普斯特德荒野（The Heath）
actually i haven't been in a while maybe i'll go this week i love the galleries i love the music opportunities i love how many people we're interviewing for the podcast that like of course i'm not going to interview them they're not going to fly to australia for it um and they're this thing about London where it can be a random Wednesday and suddenly you're like in Hackney and you're like in somebody on somebody's rooftop and like somebody's DJing and there's like and you've just made your new best friend like there's something about this environment that does just breed opportunity and good luck in many many ways so it's taught me a lot it's yeah it really has It's taught me a lot in the way that the best lessons do where they teach you the worst parts of yourself and the best parts of yourself.
其实我已经有一阵子没去了，也许这周我会去。我很喜欢那些画廊，喜欢音乐带来的机会，也喜欢我们为播客采访了那么多的人——当然我不会去采访他们，他们不会为此飞到澳大利亚的——嗯，伦敦有个特点，那就是哪怕是一个普通的周三，突然之间你好像就在哈克尼，就在某个人、某人的屋顶上，有人在打碟，然后就……你刚刚交到了你最好的新朋友。这种环境在很多很多方面确实能孕育机遇和好运，所以它教会了我很多，真的教会了我很多。它以最好的方式教会了我很多——通过让你看清自己最糟糕的一面和最好的一面。
And it's definitely taught me some of the worst parts of myself and some of the parts of me that I need to examine a little bit more. But it's also taught me how to just enjoy the moment a little bit more, how to chill out and how to say yes to more things. If you remember the episode I made when I was like, I'm moving to London, these are my expectations, this is what I want. what I said was like oh it's been difficult in the final six months of Sydney because I haven't been you know what's the point in going out because I know I'm leaving soon what's the point in getting a better co-working space because I know I'm leaving soon what's the point in upgrading or updating these things in London I just say yes to everything and that has created a busier life that I was really craving so if you are thinking about it whether or not it is your city whether or not you find that it is the place
它确实教会了我认识自己最糟糕的一些部分，以及我需要进一步审视的一些部分。但它也教会了我如何更好地享受当下，如何放松下来，以及如何对更多的事情说“好”。如果你还记得我刚说“我要搬去伦敦了，这是我的期望，这就是我想要的”时做的那期播客，我当时说的是：哦，在悉尼的最后六个月挺难熬的，因为我没有……你知道的，既然我知道自己快要走了，出去玩还有什么意义呢？既然我知道自己快要走了，弄个更好的共享办公空间有什么意义呢？既然我知道自己快要走了，升级或更新这些东西有什么意义呢？但在伦敦，我只是对一切都说“好”，这创造了我一直非常渴望的更忙碌的生活。所以，如果你正在考虑——无论这里是不是你的城市，无论你发现这里是不是那个
you have a spiritual allegiance to or whatnot, it is still worth it for the memories that you will make and for what you will learn. So what are my plans before we leave? So many things. We are doing a summer party in early August for the Psychology of your 20s in London, which is going to be so much fun. We have been just securing so many UK and Europe-based guests to come on the podcast. which I'm so glad for and I am just traveling a shit ton a shit ton and I'm trying well I'm going to
你对它有着精神上的归属感之类的地方——为了你将创造的回忆以及你将学到的东西，它依然是值得的。那么在我离开之前有什么计划呢？有好多事情。我们将在八月初在伦敦为《你二十岁的心理学》举办一场夏日派对，这将会非常有趣。我们刚刚敲定了如此多的英国和欧洲本土嘉宾来参加播客，对此我感到非常高兴，而且我正在疯狂地旅行，疯狂地旅行，并且我打算，嗯，我打算
try and do a bunch of different events in different cities so like in Copenhagen I'm going to do one we're doing one in Germany I don't know which city yet we're doing one in France we're doing one in the Netherlands oh did I already say that no in the Netherlands um and so those are kind of our plans and then sneaky on the side, I kind of want to, this is, oh my God, I can't believe maybe mention this. I forgot to mention this. I do have it in my mind that I want to move to New York for three months before we move back to Australia. Because once we move back to Australia, and isn't this the irony of like, tell God your plans and watch him laugh in your face? And I'm sure, I don't know if this will happen or not. And watch me come back on in six months and be like,
尝试在不同的城市举办各种不同的活动，比如在哥本哈根我会办一场，我们还会在德国办一场——还不知道是哪个城市，我们会在法国办一场，我们会在荷兰办一场——哦，我刚才说过了吗？没有，是在荷兰。嗯，所以这些算是我们的计划。然后偷偷地在私底下，我其实还想……天哪，我真不敢相信我可能会提到这个。我忘了提这个了。我心里确实有个想法，想在我们搬回澳大利亚之前去纽约住三个月。因为一旦我们搬回澳大利亚——这难道不是很讽刺吗？“告诉上帝你的计划，看着他在你脸上大笑”。我敢肯定，我不知道这会不会发生，看看我六个月后回来，会不会变成：
hey guys, no, we're like moving to, we're moving to Manchester and we're staying here for 10 years, like completely changing my mind but um i'm really keen to move to new york for three months once we move back to australia i think we're we're settling you know what i mean where it's i think we'll be kind of in that by the time we move back i'll be almost in my 30s what the fuck almost in my 30s and wow and um anyways oh my god realizations and yeah just ready to kind of like pursue a different chapter of life so gonna suck this fruit all the nectar from it that I can right now and that is my London update and that is my grand philosophy to be in the season that you are in as hard as I am finding it it is a guiding thing for me right now that I'm going to
“嘿，伙计们，不，我们要搬到……我们要搬到曼彻斯特去，而且我们要在那儿待十年”，就像完全改变主意一样。但嗯，一旦我们搬回澳大利亚，我真的很想去纽约住三个月。我觉得我们……我们正在安定下来，你知道我的意思吗？就是我觉得到我们搬回去的时候，我差不多就要三十岁了。天哪，快要三十岁了！哇，而且，嗯……总之，天哪，各种感悟！是的，我已经准备好去追求人生的另一个篇章了，所以现在我要尽可能地吮吸这个果实所有的甘露。这就是我的伦敦最新动态，也是我的宏大哲学：无论你身处哪个季节，都要尽情去体验，尽管我发现这很难做到，但它现在依然是我的指引，是我会
keep coming back to as my touchstone being the season I'm in being the season I'm in appreciate the moment appreciate what you're going to miss about it that is what I keep coming back to and I hope that if you, you know what, I hope that if you've moved somewhere and been like, I actually really don't like it, this makes you realize it's a pretty common experience. I hope you also realize from this episode, it's okay to say, I actually change my mind and I don't like this anymore and I don't want to do this anymore. But I also hope that you've learned to like appreciate the moment for what it is. And if you are somebody who like me at times can be kind of pessimistic and when you have high expectations for things, you know,
不断回想起的精神标杆：活在当下，活在当下，珍惜这个时刻，珍惜你会怀念它的地方。这就是我不断回想的，我希望如果你……你知道吗，我希望如果你搬到了某个地方，然后觉得“其实我真的不喜欢这里”，这能让你意识到这其实是一种相当普遍的经历。我也希望你通过这期播客意识到，你可以说“我其实改变主意了，我不再喜欢这样了，我不想再这么做了”。但我也希望你学会去欣赏当下本身的价值。如果你和我一样，有时会有点悲观，当你对事情抱有很高的期望时，你知道的，
I think sometimes it's very easy to be disappointed all the time because you expect big things from yourself. You expect big things from your experiences and sometimes it is about saying I'm just going to accept whatever happens. And I'm going to have no positive, negative, neutral, nothing, no feelings towards this except just a state of acceptance and just openness. And I feel like hopefully this episode has, I don't know, I don't want to say inspired you, but I don't even know how to say this, but just made you realize that other. people struggle with that and that we should keep our minds more open. So there you go. Thank you for listening to this episode. I know I said it was going to be a short bonus episode. I have been speaking for half an hour. If you have made it this far, what should I do in London for my last, you know what is crazy is I'm like, oh, we're leaving in June. It's still a year. I still have a year here,
我觉得有时你很容易一直感到失望，因为你对自己的期望很高，你对经历的期望很高，有时这正意味着你要说：我接受发生的一切。我对这一切都不会抱有正面、负面、中立或任何情绪，除了接受的状态和纯粹的开放心态。我希望这期播客能……我不知道，我不想说“启发了你”，但我甚至不知道该怎么说，只是让你意识到其他人也在为此挣扎，我们应该保持更开放的心态。就是这样。谢谢你收听这期播客。我知道我说过这会是一期简短的加更节目，但我已经讲了半小时了。如果你听到了这里，我在伦敦的最后这段时间应该做点什么呢？你知道最疯狂的是什么吗？我心想：“哦，我们六月要走了。”其实还有一年，我在这里还有一年——
less, we're probably going to leave in like April. But what should I do? I'm not going to be here forever. I've got less than a year. What are some London bucket list items? If you don't live in London, what are some things that you want, that if you travel to London, you would want to do, that you have done,
或者更少，我们大概会在四月左右离开。但我该做些什么呢？我又不会永远留在这里，我剩下的时间不到一年了。伦敦有什么必做清单上的项目吗？如果你不住在伦敦，你有什么想做的事——如果你去伦敦旅行，你最想做、但还没做过的，
that have been on your bucket list, I want to do those. Send them my way. Leave a comment down below. I appreciate it if you've listened this far. Again, you can follow us on Instagram. You can watch full episodes on Netflix. If you didn't already know that,
那些在你的愿望清单上的事？我都想做。发给我吧。在下方留言。如果你能听到这里，我真的很感激。再次提醒，你可以在 Instagram 上关注我们，可以在 Netflix 上观看完整节目。如果你还不知道的话，
please go and watch one. It really helps us, like, significantly, if I'm being honest. follow us on Substack, email me. I don't know, you can if you want. Yeah, email me, I guess. But yeah, it's just always, I was going to say, it's just great to talk to you. It's like I'm getting off a long phone call with my friends.
请务必去看一个。老实说，这对我们的帮助真的非常非常大。在 Substack 上关注我们，给我发邮件。好吧，如果你想的话可以。是的，发邮件给我吧，我想是的。不过，是的，一直以来……我本来想说，和你们聊天总是很棒。就像我和朋友们打完了一通长长的电话。
Where you guys have said nothing. But no, it is. It's nice to do episodes like this. So thank you for listening. Until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence, Joy 101.
虽然你们什么都没说。不过说真的，做这样的节目真的很棒。谢谢你们的收听。下次见，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。快乐至关重要，但它也很难捉摸。不过现在有一种崭新而激动人心的方式，可以开启你迈向更快乐生活旅程的大门——《快乐101》（Joy 101）。
It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby is presented by CVS. Hey, it's Alec Baldwin. This season on my podcast, Here's the Thing.
这是一档由我——霍达·科特比（Hoda Kotby）主持的新播客。如果你渴望获得灵感来最大化你的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的空中闲聊。打开免费的 iHeart Radio 应用，搜索“Joy 101”并立即收听。由 CVS 呈现的《霍达·科特比的快乐101》。
I talk to composer Mark Shaman. It's about the hang. It's the pleasure of hanging out with the people that you're with. You know, Rob and I was always a great hang. And director Morgan Neville. Film School teaches you all the wrong things about making documentary. What do you want to say? Documentary is all about your ear.
嗨，我是亚历克·鲍德温（Alec Baldwin）。本季我的播客《这就是事实》（Here's the Thing）。我与作曲家马克·沙曼（Mark Shaman）交谈。这关乎“相聚”——享受与你所在的人共度的乐趣。你知道，罗布和我在一起总是非常开心。还有导演摩根·内维尔（Morgan Neville）。电影学院教给你的关于制作纪录片的所有知识都是错的。你想表达什么？纪录片完全取决于你的听觉。
What do you hear? I feel like my job is listening really, really hard. Listen to Here's the Thing on the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. It just came out. Jeremy, what did you just do? You just sit yourself up for failure. I've never heard you tell this story.
你听到了什么？我觉得我的工作就是非常非常仔细地倾听。在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《这就是事实》。刚刚发布。杰米，你刚才做了什么？你简直是给自己挖了个失败的坑。我从来没听你讲过这个故事。
I have never told this story. This must have been tucked deep, deep in the Jeremy Lin file. My name is MC Jen. I'm excited to tell you about laugh but not least. I'll be chatting with guests from all walks of life about the power of humor when it comes to facing difficult times. These will be conversations that remind us all, life is hard. Laugh harder.
我从来没讲过这个故事。这一定是被深深地、深深地藏在了林书豪的档案里。我是 MC 珍（MC Jen）。我很高兴向大家介绍《笑到最后》（Laugh But Not Least）。我将与各行各业的嘉宾畅聊面对艰难时期时幽默的力量。这些对话将提醒我们所有人：生活艰难，笑得更响亮。
Listen to laugh but not least with MCJN on the IHeart Radio app, podcast or wherever you get your podcast. Happy pride from the Outspoken Podcast Network. All month long and all year round, we're celebrating being loud, proud, and always original. It's me, Brandon Kyle Goodman, host of the podcast, Tell Me Something Messy. Check out my show for unfiltered takes on dating, relationships, and adulting. Listen to High Key for the best pop culture takes, and there are no girls on the internet
在 iHeart Radio 应用、播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听由 MCJN 主持的《笑到最后》。来自“直言不讳播客网络”（Outspoken Podcast Network）的骄傲月快乐。整个月乃至一整年，我们都在庆祝自己声音响亮、骄傲自豪且永远独一无二。我是布兰登·凯尔·古德曼（Brandon Kyle Goodman），播客《告诉我一些凌乱的事》（Tell Me Something Messy）的主持人。收听我的节目，获取关于约会、人际关系和成年生活的无过滤观点。收听《High Key》获取最佳流行文化观点，还有《互联网没有女孩》（There are No Girls on the Internet）
for all your tech news. For your favorite celebrity key keys, check outlaws with T.S. Madison. Learn to love yourself unapologetically with BFF, Black Fat Fem, and start your day with intention with waking up with Ryan coming in July. Celebrate Pride with the Outspoken Network. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Pride and listen now. This Black Music Month, the Questlove show celebrates the visionaries,
获取你的所有科技新闻。想要了解你最喜欢的名人八卦，请查看 T.S. 麦迪逊（T.S. Madison）主持的《Outlaws》。通过 BFF（Black Fat Fem）学会毫不内疚地爱自己，并在七月即将播出的由瑞安（Ryan）主持的《用觉醒开启一天》（Waking Up with Ryan）中带着意图开始新的一天。与“直言不讳网络”一同庆祝骄傲月。打开你的免费 iHeart Radio 应用，搜索“Pride”并立即收听。在这个黑人音乐月，奎斯特洛夫秀（The Questlove Show）致敬那些通过声音塑造文化的远见者。
shaping culture, through sound. From country trailblazer Mickey Gaiden to hip-hop icon Fat 5 Freddie, the sonic genius of Thundercat, and the revolutionary voice of Chuck D. I want it loud. So the timing might be off, the sound might be muffled, but what's going to come out of there is something that you can feel. Celebrate Black Music Month with special episodes of The Questlove Show.
从乡村音乐先驱米基·盖顿（Mickey Guyton）到嘻哈偶像胖子弗雷迪（Fatlip Freddie），再到雷霆猫（Thundercat）的声波天才，以及查克·D（Chuck D）的革命性嗓音。我希望声音响亮。所以时机可能不对，声音可能会有些沉闷，但从那里传出来的将会是你能够感受到的东西。通过《奎斯特洛夫秀》的特别节目来庆祝黑人音乐月。
Listen on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个 iHeart 播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。